David giving us a talk and intro
geography
David please start again yeah hi so yeah
let me first thank the organizers
tremendously for defying the challenges
of the virus and organizing this
fantastic workshop so in fact I'm going
to give two Talk's today in one timeslot
first I was asked by the organizers to
give a general introduction to quantum
state tomography which I'm happy to do
but I will also talk about some more
recent and original resides in the
second part namely about testing and a
clear for symmetry okay and slight
transition not quite working it okay so
introduction to tomography there's going
to be three points what is the point of
tomography that's a more subtle question
than people might think what are the
problems and then I will talk very
quickly about four different technical
approaches to quantum state tomography
so that you can get some feeling for
kind of like the techniques the
theoretical techniques that people are
using okay
so the definition of wanna stay
tomography is of course the task to
estimate a quantum state go from
measurements performed on n copies of
that state first why is it called
tomography of course by tomography
people have these medical these medical
pictures in mind and the reason is that
historically it was first introduced for
in quantum optics where people like to
use this Wigner representation of the
density matrix and there's a very
natural measurement you can do in
quadratic s-- which is called homodyning
and in homodyning you can integrate
along a given direction with this phase
space distribution right here
and from these marginals you can then
reconstruct the for distribution and
that is the same algorithm the radon
transform that is used in medical
tomography equipment and the name has
stuck also of course to for scheme the
to not use this radon transform at all
okay so why should I not you
quantum state tomography and the obvious
first answer is that it's it's doomed if
you go to big hollow system it's doomed
by the exponential number of parameters
that you would have to estimate it
competes against efficient certification
protocols are like like randomized
benchmarking for example that that are
efficient it is in critical in bigger
systems and and Robin is going to talk
about that on Thursday and it's also as
we will see now surprisingly non-trivial
there's all the reasons why tomography
still has a role to play in quantum
technology and yeah let's say for
example you want to implement a a
quantum gate you want to implement a
certain state and you run your let's say
randomized benchmarking protocol and it
tells you it's not quite good enough
what it does not tell you would these
certifications protocol what they do not
tell you is in which way the physical
implementation deviates from its
specification yeah so this kind of
information you need to water v4 and
also that's a practical reason well of
course there's also a fundamental reason
I think it's a fundamental primitive of
quantum information processing the
question how many samples for example do
I need in order to characterize the
state of a system so I guess we owe it
to the gods of mathematical physics to
who to explore it here's a example of my
first point so that's a plot from an
experimental collaboration that I was
involved in a few years ago I was a
group of hard wine folder and there the
task was to characterize the state of
a66
of an optical six qubit state of an
optical six cubed system and the goal
was to prepare a totally symmetric what
is called a symmetric dickey state
that's like a DHS that state it's like a
state of of six cubits where you have a
uniform is symmetrically distributed
three three excitations and it is it is
this setting had lot of structure it was
permutation invariant so we could reduce
the tomography to the to the eigenspaces
of the permutation operator so here the
the plot you're seeing here is for the
totally symmetric subspace
the state also turned out to be low
ranked and so we use compressed sensing
I will talk about this a bit later and
here are the matrix elements or so
density matrix plotted in the basis
given by symmetric States and you see is
this center point here that is the the
target said people wanted to create but
the fidelity is only 0.5 and so what
tomography tells you is that all that it
tells you where all the rest of the
fidelity is in these two bars and they
turn out to be the Dickey state where
one photon has been lost and the Dickey
state where one too many photons has
been injected into the system so you get
diagnostic information out of a
tomographic protocol that you might I
may be able to use as an experimentalist
to improve your setup right so from a
theory point of view in particular what
are the problems that people think about
why it is still an active field of
research right ok so the first big
problem that is unique to quantum state
tomography as opposed to classical state
estimation is the design problem and we
have to decide which measurements should
one perform so we get these yeah we get
this n copies of the state and now what
do we do and there's a bunch of
different frameworks for how you can
analyze that first in the in the the
strongest one you can assume that you
are allowed to do a global entangled
measurement of all these n states
yeah that's of course not realistic
often in practice so the next best thing
to do is to to do it locally yeah so on
every copy of the state you perform you
perform one measurement and then no
coherence is allowed yeah then there's
another distinction namely adaptive
versus identical measurements do you
adapt future measurements based on past
outcomes and there is an even more
fine-grained description which is
closest to realistic experiments that is
where like even a single copy might be
an n cubed system and the measurements
do perform have to be local even within
a a single copy so let's call this maybe
the local local
framework this is least looked at by
theory but most relevant practically
yeah and other questions you have to ask
yourself I do you allow yourself
to perform arbitrary PMS or only based
measurements only to outcome
measurements all of these decisions give
you very different theories yeah and so
probably the most relevant and the least
understood I think I come back to this
in the end
is it's a local product basis
measurement yeah for example here's a
picture from an iron trap yeah where the
experimentalist for every I and they
choose one basis and then they can
simultaneously measure in the diving
basis of every iron OOP all right okay
so now there was a slight transition I
didn't intend but actually it's good I
was done with this one so once you've
you've made a decision for the design
what to measure the next problem is the
estimation problem so how do you now we
have classical data out of the
measurement machine and now we have to
turn it into some kind of information
some kind of reconstruction of the true
state yeah and already there again
there's many different decisions one can
make what to look for first one has to
decide what is the goal of the procedure
say I want a point estimate where I just
get one estimate for the state do I want
the region estimate where it gives me an
entire region maybe like something like
a higher dimensional error bar that's
compatible with the measurements maybe
I'm a Bayesian and I want the posterior
distribution over States yeah so all
these give you different theories then
you can care to try to quantify them the
performance of a reconstruction scheme
there's many different X's also here you
might care about the computational
complexity about the sample complexity
how many copies of the state do I need
you might measure your determinations
and trace non - non fidelity and what
has been a big topic in in the past
years is you might want to exploit
structure so it turns out that there are
some classes of states for which it's
much easier to reconstruct them for
others for example they're very pure
it's much easier if they have symmetries
it's much easier or if they have an
effusion in anybody representation often
also turns out to be much easier all
right okay so of course this is a yeah
entire like libraries have been written
about this so I have to make it like a
choice of what to do in this talk and I
will only talk about point estimates no
Bayesian
soft Norwegian estimation I will if I
compare schemes I will talk about the
semper complexity that is required to
reach an expected trace norm error and I
will always comment on whether or not
rhythms are capable of exploiting lauric
yeah okay so again I mean there is uh
alright sorry yeah so there's there is
infinitely many schemes that have been
proposed I will talk about four
theoretically interesting ones but
before I do this I want to talk about
what practitioners actually do because
here we are on serious issues but in
reality people do quantum state
tomography just fine and in the lab so
what what are they doing so if you if
you open a journal and you find a
excellent experimentally reconstructed
state like here then most likely people
have been using maximum likelihood point
estimations and maximum likelihood to
get point estimates so maximum
likelihood estimation what you do is you
take the data that you got and then you
optimize over all possible states and
your estimate is the state under which
the probability of seeing that data
would have been highest so that's
maximum likelihood estimation as a
general framework that always works in
statistics and then they use what is
called a bootstrap strategy for
uncertainty quantification let me not
talk about this here right so what how
do we feel about the state of the art of
experimental practice yeah first
question that an ex mentalists can ask
so what I've been doing all these years
is that that sound is that a good thing
to do even that you theoreticians are
still talking about a tomography and the
answer is yeah that's okay if you do
maximum likelihood estimation if we do
good swapping you will not make major
mistakes some people say they've heard
that maximum likelihood estimation is in
fact optimal and so there's no reason to
look at any other estimators
yeah that's already a bit more
complicated because these optimality
results they do exist
but they are true only asymptotically if
you have very many samples and they are
also only true away from the boundary of
the statistical model which in our case
meets only four full ranks
and neither assumption is terribly
irrelevant to quantum experiments so
every is not as optimal as people might
think and then sometimes the discussion
gets a bit like yeah controversial
because people often claim with high
confidence that maximum likelihood gives
you the state that is most likely given
the data and that is what you should be
doing that what the data tells you in
fact Ronald Fisher a pioneer of
Statistics settles this question in the
1920s when he invented ml e and because
his British is actually at night so you
want to argue with them so stop wasting
your time thinking of about about new
estimators and so that's rent I've heard
at least once people say that and yeah
so people seem to have very strong
opinions about estimators for some
reason I don't quite know why that is
and and the sentiment of years based on
a misconception namely the word likely
sounds in everyday English it's a
pseudonym for probable and probable has
an operational meaning but but the
likelihood does not yeah so likelihood
sounds like it should have a meaning but
it doesn't most likely is a vacuous
statement that should not be confused
with a statement of of the estimate
being the most probable in some sense
and and so yeah the summary years at
Emory what people use it's okay it is
neither as optimal nor as canonic as
some people think and even if it were
still we would need theory to analyze
its performance so even though people do
perform quantum state tomography there's
a lot of theory left to be done okay so
now for when Emily chosen approaches
from the literature over the past years
that have chosen based on what I like
and one or four is called
the approach of local asymptotic
normality and it's a longer research
program that has been carried out by a
model in Bhutan and you know Scott and I
will try to give you a one slide summary
of this extensive theory and I will only
look at the simplest possible
namely estimating a single qubit pure
state and of course I can do it in full
generality and it is based on a mapping
that is sometimes known as as premark of
time and it works like this so let's say
we we choose one reference state size
zero zero so for example here look
yeah here this is my block sphere and
size zero zero is the red dot there and
now I consider a family of states that
are close to it but I may be displaced a
bit along the blocks here by these
placements Delta X and Delta Z yeah so
in some some region of the block see
here so now it turns out and this is not
obvious but it turns out that there is a
channel lambda that takes states of this
form and it takes many copies and copies
and it will map these n copies of spin
one-half states and we map them to
Gaussian States on a quantum harmonic
oscillator and the displacement on the
Bloch sphere will be mapped to the first
moments Delta X data Y of this Gaussian
stage so if we wanted yeah the
displacement will be mapped to the
position into the momentum and
expectation value of a quantum harmonic
oscillator and this channel turns out to
be a trace norm isometry for large n
yeah so if you go to many copies you can
do the statistical analysis in phase
space for harmonic oscillators and not
not just for spins and so Maddalena and
you know scan they propose to base as
estimation on that yeah so the idea is
to first we find a rough estimate of the
state and uses as our reference state so
uses as the anchor point for this map
then we implement this map lambda and
map yeah map the spin States to two
harmonic oscillators and then use
heterodyne measurements to find the
first moments which are known to be
optimal and so what are the summary of
the performance of that so the scheme is
optimal in terms of central complexity
for fixed dimension so some follower
papers have recently
yeah shown that it's not actually
optimal if the skating is not actually
optimal in the dimension and less
somebody doesn't get the message it's of
course completely ridiculous no it's one
of these mathematical physics type of
results which are very beautiful
mathematically but of course in reality
you do not want to couple 1000 spins to
a harmonic oscillator in order to
estimate the displacement of the Bloch
sphere okay
so two of the four schemes and I want to
talk about is associated with four names
kine and Jana these are the quantum
information names and then classically
short vile because it uses
representation theory so let's start by
building kind of a line let's talk about
what their ideas so the basic idea is to
take the density operator and write it
as as you and diagonal matrix with the
with the spectrum on its major bathe
main diagonal and u dagger so I have to
say you that that since some time I'm
trying to transition from large egg
slides to PowerPoint and I don't know
how to make a dagger in PowerPoint so I
use the mathematical notation here
somebody can tell me how to make a deck
up please write me an email
okay so now the basic idea is to
estimate the spectrum and the eigenbasis
separately and in fact let's in this
talk only concentrate on how to estimate
the spectrum yeah so that's the spectrum
estimation problem if you have n copies
of a state estimated spectrum there
should be a P naught lambda right so
what is the answer
so the basic answers is to realize that
the problem we are facing is invariant
both under unit Ares if I change the
basis the spectrum stays the same but
also under permutation of all these M
copies so it might be natural to try to
find P VMs that commute with both these
symmetries commute with your gear and
commute with SM right and now we come to
the second set of names issue and why
because of course that's a classical
result only show a wide reality which
would play
also a rule in the second part of my
talk how to find these PMS you have the
finest PMS that one can one can possibly
implement that commute both with basis
changes and with mutations okay so the
first realization is that local basis
changes and permutation of systems
actually they commute amongst themselves
yeah if I first changed the basis
everywhere and then commuter systems or
do the other way around it doesn't
matter and there are two different ways
of making of strengthening that
statement and the first one is to
realize that not only do these two
operations commute but they are maximal
with this property they are each other's
comments in the sense that an operator a
commutes with any base basis change if
and only if it is a linear combination
of permutations and vice versa so that
is like the algebraic characterization
of sure while but there's also a
representation theoretic
characterization of short while which
will also need and it follows from from
the left hand side actually and and you
do the following you take the the total
Hilbert space and then you decompose it
into irreducible representations of
permutations and unitary simultaneously
and you get some yeah direct Sun and
they are labeled by some objects lambda
I'll talk about next and for every
summon you get a Europe of the
permutation group tends when Europe of
the unitary group and every summit here
if you defines a projection operator if
P lambda is the projection operator on
to on to the lambda some and then by
shows lemma P lambda commutes with both
of these actions and and also forms a
POV M because it's a complete set of
projections alright so then the idea of
Kyle and Vanna many years ago was to
let's perform this measurement right so
we get n we get M copies of the state we
make these P lambda measurements which
are in tank measurements on all of them
and we get out label lambda and of
course now the problem we are facing now
is how to turn lambda into
in into an estimate of the spectrum so
in order to explain this I have to
explain you how these representations
are labeled so what are these lambdas
and it turns out the research lambda is
a partition of the number n into no more
than B parts so for example if I have
six copies
yeah three-to-one would be one of these
one of these lambdas they often
visualized as young frames in this way
yeah where I I draw a number of boxes in
a horizontal row corresponding to the
number in the partition okay and now you
see now I do something okay so now I get
one of these partitions but I need to
guess a spectrum so how do I do this and
okay I don't know what your what your
job description looks like but of course
I spent a lot of time not doing unlike
where you're teaching and and the worst
possible thing that can happen to you
and aquaria teaching I mean often it's
it's fantastic and so a warding it you
get created students but sometimes you
are unlucky and you get students who do
not understand any concepts at all and
just argue based on form and
similarities no I mean you make a
lecture on quantum information and you
write GHD onto the board and then you
ask the student and they say yeah
clearly that's a frequency measure its
gigahertz yeah and so we cannot make the
exact same mistake here and we do
something that is ludicrous so we we we
get this this number which has like a
communitarian origin and we want to get
out of spectrum so what we could do is
purely formally we normalize it by
dividing this partition by the total
number of elements in it and then we get
a formal probability distribution and
and we can say that's our guess for the
spectrum yeah and of course if a student
were to put it on me at like would like
to make them fail immediately and as I
put my hand to the paper to like sign
the paper that would flank them out of
university then from a vacuum
fluctuation Kyle and Jana appear in the
room and say no that's actually the
right answer that's actually what you
should do this turns out to be a near
optimal estimator of of the spectrum
okay so the theory goes back many years
I think early early 2000s is not not
even earlier and then it took 15 years
before people have completed it to an a
complete tomography protocol the
performance of which they could analyze
and these were two papers simultaneously
by Hart island and on a little many of
the authors here are actually
participants in the workshop and they
say okay the it turns out that the
complexity of now finding the eigen
basis given the spectrum is comparable
to the complexity of estimating the
spectrum itself it's not actually very
difficult to explain how that works but
I have limited time so I skip it now and
and they and what more importantly they
they can actually compute it and they
find that the number of samples you need
to estimate a quantum state that has
rank R in d dimensions is of the order
of Rd over epsilon squared where epsilon
squared is a trace norm ever Europe
you're likely to make and they also at
least one of the first paper they
provide Congress bounds and they show
that this is an optimal scaling the
measurements are non-local as I said
before so that's a disadvantage but they
do have efficient circuits yeah they're
given by the quantum schewe transform
okay so this is 2 or 4 no this is
compared to tomorrow with purely local
measurements yeah that's right I would
come to that next so the question was
out of that compared to purely local
measurements I come back to that in just
five minutes when I discussed the
following proposal which which which I
my surfers have spent a lot of time
thinking about but it's a reason for
only devoting one slide to it so I would
be very brief and it's called corporate
sensing and it starts not from a
statistical question but from a
parameter counting question
so forget about statistics for now let's
again decompose on the unknown density
operator in sighing bases and let's
assume it has no rank so rank R which we
assume is low then we see that it
actually depends on our deep around
no because this our summons and every
summoned has roughly D parameters to
specify it
that's much fewer than V squared which
is the naive matrix dimension so the
compare sensing question is can one
recover a rank R matrix from order Rd
expectation values yeah so I choose D
different Rd different Commission
operators I estimate these expectation
values and just by parameter counting it
should be enough to recover Rho but it's
not obvious how to do it because even
though these are few parameters they are
of course not linear subspace no the set
of rank R density operators is somehow a
complicated variety and so I could not
try something very naive because I want
to have something no rank so I could
find let's set up the following
optimization problem where I look at the
lowest rank solution that is compatible
with the data that I have now this
doesn't actually work because minimizing
the rank is numerically unstable of
course because the rank is a non
continuous function and actually it's
it's empty heart in general to find the
lowest rank element of an of an affine
subspace so it's not even that a better
egg wasn't good in general resolve that
but it turns out and this is the
mathematical result of compressed
sensing that is the semi definite
programming programming relaxation of
this of this optimization here which
minimizes not the rank but the trace
norm of candidate objects and this works
efficiently for almost all measurements
yeah so the np-hardness reside is the
worst case result that does not affect
the the average case yeah and this was
it's a theory that originated in the in
the Bay Area know at at at Stanford
University by to know and Kandace and
was the hottest thing in single analysis
and machine learning and to deep
learning suck the air out of everything
that's not a neural network and so yeah
at the time it was who theory to do for
that here is a summary yeah so pumper
sensing tells you you can recover from
order of our times the observables even
which is optimal so I haven't talked
about statistics at all but one can
build just parameter counting
build a statistical estimation protocol
around these insights and this works to
answer Henry's question this works in
the local local model where it gives you
a scaling which is a bit worse than
before because now you have a square
dependency on R but this is optimal in
the local model and yeah so that's it
and yeah that's representing David yeah
what how good is the relaxation the SDP
no solution ah
so in the absence of noise it is exact
so so the the minimizer here so if there
is if they let's forget about noise
statistical noise systemic noise if
there is lowering solution then for
almost all measurement it will be found
exactly exactly by the SDP yeah it's the
best you can hope for all measurements
sorry almost all measurements so yeah
okay so the the entire theory is about
making that precise so that is kind of
like a it's like a template proof
template and then if we have a given
measurement scheme you try to to prove
that for your particular ensemble it
works so the first result that that we
had there for colonization lottery was
you take just takes us poly matrices to
outcome podium matrices and then there's
d squared poly matrices and you just sub
sample our times D of them randomly and
then the tie probability this will work
well non-local it's two outcomes so it's
correlations but it's like factorizing
correlations yeah so it's somewhere
between local and local local mm-hmm but
also there is there is yeah there is
this second paper I cited here by by by
Richard where Pope where what I'm going
to say no wait I take this back so it's
all it's all it's all local and in the
first paper it's kind of local local
because the the measurement that they
completely factorize if you want
okay any more questions
alright then I go to my the fire thing
the final paper I want to I want to
promote and I think it's really
fantastic and it's very new and it's a
bit overlooked so find I hope this will
change and it's it's a dead simple
approach is really ridiculously simple
and and and of course a strong thing is
that it works very well so so you do the
estimation process you break down into
two steps so first you take data so fi
is again like some expectation value
epsilon I can measure the noise and and
you do it for an over complete set of
observables and then you want to map it
back to a density operator and you
firstly do the simple thing anybody can
think of name you find the least squares
fit to to the data you you've got yeah
so that's very easy to analyze
analytically and it's very easy to do
numerically but the big disadvantage is
it will not give you a density operator
because it will give you a mission
operator that might have negative
eigenvalues so in the next step you
modify the eigenvalues in order to
project to the closest density operator
yeah so very simple operations extremely
simple and the amazing thing is this
works extremely well yeah it's yeah
there's it's simple to do it simple to
analyze comparatively it gives optimal
scaling for local and some local local
models and more importantly it is the
only the only proposal I know about that
treats this experimentally relevant case
of product basis measurements and gives
some bounds here yeah so we're again
here for in this ion trap you would
choose like one basis for every iron to
measure in and the number of copies
needed here is R square times D to the
wine one point six and it is possible
that D to the for the first power it
still it's still achievable we don't
know that and I think this is an a very
relevant open problem whether for this
particularly physically relevant
measurement setting one can achieve an
exponent of one there and yeah it's done
it was done for example by by which I
can use the next speaker
and also my model in Goethe and and mr.
Kahn who came up with local asymptotic
normality so the first scheme they
devised like a decade ago was completely
impractical but super nice
mathematically and now a decade later
they are the co-authors on the most
practical well analyzed scheme did I
know about okay
summary quantum state tomography is
relevant in practice which in theory and
that's all I have in terms of summary so
that ends my first part of the talks or
a very high-level bird's eye overview
about what day is to do and to be
thought about in quantum state to
moderate can you comment on the adapter
yes right okay so the person who did the
most or like early papers on that that I
know of us is Robin Bluth who's of
course in the panel so maybe he can
answer and that it the answer is it
helps in the where's my classification
in the beginning it helps in the local
but not at the local local case okay let
me say this so in the in the local case
there is a paper by Robin that says
adaptivity here helps a lot and I can't
make it precise now we would have to ask
Robin and in the local local case where
adaptivity is allowed for but
constrained to respect a subdivision of
into subsystems of every single copy it
doesn't help at all which is a result by
you can use different year and myself so
sometimes it helps and sometimes not
yeah thank you I think David's coverage
of the adaptive question was you know
excellent there are earlier references
though before the work that we did um
David I had a quick question about
projected least-squares yeah you
mentioned the sort of recent references
is this different from what IBM
published back in 2012 under the
original title of maximum
they heard minimum effort I'm not sure
the difference is they have a
theoretical guarantees for center
complexity in a number of different
scenarios so this this is so I mean the
the idea is of course I said that
simpler right and and and certainly
they're not the only ones to do with
this also if you do a maximum likelihood
and certain asymptotic regimes you will
in the end back to something that
extremely similar what they could do is
just why I think it's relevant is like
they have these performance guarantees
which I don't think anybody else has I
don't know maybe I've overlooked it but
certainly I've reloaded from them maybe
Richard wants to say something okay but
he might be preparing this talk so it's
not no no I'm here yeah um well similar
ideas I know that Peter Turner did
similar ideas in 2012 but they didn't
use a matrix perched and inequality but
classical entry wise 15 pounds and so
they don't get the right rank dependence
that's the one reference that I know
that is very similar so okay so I think
my summaries I don't want to give them
credit to the idea which I think has
been has been around for a long time but
I do want to give them credit for
realizing that it's it's it's very easy
to to to show performance currently so
very easy I don't know but comparatively
easy certainly much easier than the
other three things the other three
approaches I introduced before if any
any other question
then okay good to have all the experts
and authors actually in attendance if
that is so I would transition to
something absolutely completely
different and talk about a research
program that I've been pursuing since
since some time and and I had the honor
to work with a set of really brilliant
co-authors on this how do I there right
so it's it's easy to have good results
if you have good quarters so that's good
it's it's yeah we could work another
since 2018 so maybe some of you have
seen bits of this presentation before in
which case I apologize there's always
new results that the the gift that keeps
on giving
so let me try to motivate this research
from the point of view of testing and
and and in reference back to the first
part of the talk all right okay so let's
recall this testing under symmetry that
kind of question that we looked at
before namely that we encountered in the
in the spectrum estimation problem yeah
so we wanted to find the spectrum of
correction of density matrices and we
found an optimal pvm for solving that
problem by exploiting the unitary and
the permutation symmetry and so the the
question I want to ask here now in the
remainder of the time is what if we
replace unitary by clifford invariance
and here is one question that initially
motivated our research there's like long
list of application now ever-growing
that will come next but this was
actually the original question so the
the lot tech file if you download the
paper from the archive the logic file is
still called after those problems called
stabilizer testing attack and so the the
problem is a problem in in quantum
property testing and actually and the
wolf they asked the following question
namely is there a number T that is
dimension independent such that from T
copies of given pure state side of the
density one can decide with ups is a
stabilizer state or whether science far
away
from the set of stabilizer States yeah
so that's a question yeah it's not clear
that this works and I mentioned in an
independent way I mean you could do
tomography we construct I look at what
it is but that of course is very much
not dimension independence so is there
yeah it said like purity is this a
testable quality right and yeah we want
to decide this and last time yeah of
course this question again also has yeah
it has the the symmetries are advertised
know the the it is permutation very end
and of course also because clear forward
operations mixtape as the states the
stabilizer states it is stable actually
fall invariant and so in order to
retrace the steps we did before it would
be good if we had a show while duality
kind of theory for the clifford group
yeah and this is what we work hard to
develop yeah so let's look back at so
wide reality to see what we what we are
aiming for yeah so that's where the
slide I had before there's one
difference from the previous slide may
be that the number number of copies is
not quality and not n that's because I
need to know the letter n for a
different purpose and you will see that
on my next slide
yeah and we found that the competent of
the unit Ares is are exactly the
permutations and there were two ways of
expressing it the simpler I deprived way
and the more sophisticated
representation of theoretic way and so
for the Clifford group we can now say
something about both on the left hand
side I think we can conclusively like
describe the theory on the right hand
side there is significant progress but
there also needs is work left to be done
so I will focus on one and if I have
time which doesn't really look like it
at the moment but if I have time I will
tell you a bit about two which is
something I'm very excited about but
it's also very technical unfortunately
ok so again before we generalize let's
record a very nice property of sure why
do ality that we will be fortunate
enough to recapture yeah and so we it
should learn it at first so that we know
what we have
so we now assume that like every single
every single hilbert space that we look
at already has a subdivision like my
local local scenario before we look at
key copies but every single copy is
already composed
out of n quantum system let's say n
qubits yeah and because it's going to be
they I have now a two dimensional tensor
product structure and so because it's
it's a bit annoying to reason the bosses
are probably it's introduced a graphical
notation yeah so a a dot represents this
CD and every single system here is
composed of n such dots and I have a
unitary you acting on this end system
simultaneously and now I take T copies
of them and the copies I know the notes
in a vertical fashion and right and and
recall that the the commitment of all
these unit Ares was given by
permutations and you know that
permutations actually transversally yeah
so if I want to permute n yeah and a
composite system based are comprised of
n sub systems I can first do the
permutation like among the first systems
then among the second systems and so on
whoa yeah so so yeah permutations egg
transversely and this means that I have
very symmetric situations situation here
both algebras the one generated power
the unit heavies and the one generated
by all the permutations they have a
product basis and they act kind of with
respect to incompatible or like
orthogonal directions in my
two-dimensional diagram and they both
form groups yes these are very nice
properties of the show by reality and
this product basis form this we will
recover for the Clifford group this is
surprising and the second we won't quite
recover but we'll get close enough so
that's also very good all right yeah so
yeah some some remarks on prior results
if we replace the clifford group the
unitary group has a clifford group what
was known before so it was known that
the clifford group is a so called
unitary tea design which means for two
copies you don't find any new
phenomenology for three copies it was
later also shown that you don't
and this was done in 2015 by no fewer
than three authors at the same time
we're actually hyungjoon's ooh I had
just higher than before like and then
like the the first week he working he
put our competing papers on the archives
but it was already explicit in work and
in representation invariant theory like
a decade earlier
and yeah and for once you once you go to
four copies something new new effect
start to emerge and and what we want to
do is you want to find the general
theory now for every team there's many
applications which I don't want to talk
about at all I just have a long list of
applications so that you know I don't
just do algebra because like I should
probably there's applications but I
don't actually want to talk about them
you sorry I I would like to ask what is
the what is the difference between T and
the D T and T okay yeah that's this is
unfortunately our three parameters just
to confuse you
yeah so every single system is a
d-dimensional quantum system let's say
let's take D equal to true which means
we have qubits and then for the rest of
my talk that should be good enough yeah
and now I want to look at unit Ares that
act on c2 to the end
yes was the piece of the unitary stacked
here horizontally yeah and now I take T
of these t copies of those yeah so there
are three parameters local dimension
number of subsystems of of a single copy
and number of copies okay right and all
right so yeah so I will only have time
for the algebraic reside unfortunately
let me state what it is so here's a
statement of the main result and then I
will need two slides to explain to you
what I actually met all right so the
statement is that the commitment of the
t's tens of powers of the cleaver group
is generated by again tens of powers of
n two different type of objects so
called discrete orthogonal
transformations and self orthogonal CSS
code projections okay so of course
nobody understands what I'm doing here
so let me take some time to walk you
through the statement
so the first object I have to introduce
are of discreet orthogonal
transformations and what I do is the
following I take a matrix o with
increase in ZD and remember we only
talked about qubits so I take a matrix
with entries in Z 2 so just a matrix
with 0 1 entries and I call it
orthogonal if it fulfills the usual
definition of normal matrix but I only
require it to do this mordy because
everything what to in this case
everything is integers so it's a
combinatorial definition of a rotation
and and then these orthogonal whoa did
my video just shut down huh ok because
your video was partially blocking some
of your slides on the stream so yeah
thank you so all right so so these
orthogonal matrices they will act as a
replacement of the permutations yeah so
one way to fulfill it one example for
this would be if if always a permutation
matrix yeah but but but now we have a
bigger group so they are also they are
binary matrices that are not
permutations but still orthogonal in
that sense so now we get a bigger
commitment as we should because we're
looking at the commitment of a smaller
group a smaller group has more things
commuting with it
so how do these orthogonal matrices act
on my state space and they act as
following so now we we look again at
this gigantic monster of a two
dimensional set of tensor products and
so I can find the basis in here and the
in the basis is I just choose one
computational basis state for every one
of these dots so the the basis is
labeled by by a matrix of computational
basis states and then the permutations
if I had a permutation it would just
permute the rows of this matrix and a
more general action than permuting the
rows of the matrix is to rotate them
into each other so I can
a basis element and Method 2 another
basis element that is kind of a rotated
version of the first one we are now from
the left I act with a visit with an
authorial matrix that need not be a
permutation yeah so that's the first
ingredient and let me give you an
example of such a matrix that is not a
permutation but it's orthogonal and our
favorite examples are the so-called anti
permutations and by anti permutations I
mean the binary complement of a
permutation matrix for example that is
the binary complement of the identity
matrix we call it the anti identity and
take the identity matrix and you
substitute once by zeroes yeah and then
this turns out to be to be in element
also committed right so what does it do
yeah if we have such a two-dimensional
array of quantum systems it takes our 1
column yeah and if you check what this
does it does the following if if the
parity of this of this binary vector if
it's if the parity is odd then it flips
all the bits but if the parity is even
then it does nothing yeah so that what
it means to rotate stuff in a discrete
way doesn't look like a continuous
rotation of course but that's what it is
ok so then the second ingredient I don't
have to spend so much time on because
these are just CSS projection for the
CSS codes yeah which I think most of you
know if not I will actually skip over
this these are just stabilizer counts a
particular form of stabilizer codes ok
and now I can state the the result again
and it says that the the content of tens
of powers of clifford operations is is
given by tens of powers of either
orthogonal matrices or of CSS code
projections so again i have a trans
versality yeah i have a trans insanity
good condition here but I don't have
transversal permutations but these funky
or soreness all these funky projections
and not quite a group so this part of
the group but the CSS code part of
courses is not it's not a group yeah so
this we can now analyze representation
theoretically but I won't have time
today to talk about it
maybe in the final five minutes I come
back to the motivating question namely
what are applications there's a long
list of applications but the application
I advertise because it fits our theme of
the workshop is this property testing
application so we have talked about
additional symmetries of Clifford unit
Ares but they translate actually two
additional symmetries of stabilizer
States yeah so in terms now we do the
same game as before but now we don't
look at unit Ares we do get sticks so I
take a stabilizer state on n qubits and
attend setup T times and it's
permutation symmetric obviously but it's
it has a bigger symmetry group yeah
because from the theory that I've just
described it follows that the tens of
powers of stabilizer states are also
invariant under the structure and the do
and is the discrete orthogonal group
please ignore the stock has two here
that's detail I swept another run today
and here's the proof but I don't give
the proof so so the symmetry extends to
from unitary to stabilizer States and
now we can use it to answer this the
question that that the open problem is
stabilizer in in quantum property
testing namely we could just take on a
state we can we can tensor at T times
and then we can check whether it is an
eigenstate of let's say a random a
random orthogonal matrix but it turns
out there is actually a much better
theorem that we can prove namely it it
suffices to check whether a whether a
state is an eigenstate of the six by six
empty identity that that is enough so
only stabilizer states have that
property yeah so so here's our
stabilizer testing protocol so we
measure the projection onto the plus one
eigen space of the anti identity on six
copies and then if size stabilize are no
matter on how many qubits
we will accept this probability one this
I've already said but also the converse
is true if if the sy has small overlap
with any stabilizer state then it's
unlikely that this test accept accepts
yeah and this solves this open problem
it is in fact because we use
representation theory we can prove all
kind of optimality statements very much
like the spectrum estimation before yeah
sorry yeah you're already reading ahead
so this is optimal in terms of the
degree equal to 6 so you can't do it
with fewer than 6 it's also optimal in
terms of the error probability now we
can also test an unknown unitary whether
it's a Clifford unitary or not this
works the same way yeah so we can test
for 4/3 fourtner's property of unit Ares
and the test is transversal circuit I
don't know which is very easy to
describe so yeah so with the theory we
cannot do clifford invariant your test
for clifford invariant properties ok so
then there's many other applications we
came up with I don't want to talk about
them if you like mana and face space
simulation there's applications there if
you like divinities we have a fantastic
exponential divinity theorem that works
much better than the old one it just
uses of course because symmetry or Sorel
instead of just permutation we have
applications to stabilizer rank
fantastic theory I will not talk about
any of that designs I will not talk
about it but I want to advertise a paper
that just came out a few weeks ago which
is another application which to the
delight of sigh wait we called quantum
homeopathy for reasons that will become
clear in a second and here the starting
observation is that Clifford's they form
a unitary 3 design and the question is
how many non clear thoughts do I have to
add to a professor which were upgraded
to a tea design yes I want to analyze
circuit of this form we have n qubits
and in an interleaved way I perform a
clipper operation then like non Clifford
single qubit gate Clifford runs in a non
Clifford single qubit gate and so on for
K layers and the question is how big
does K have to be before the thing if I
randomize the the Clifford path before
it converges to a unitary T design and
the theorem is not many so we have we
have the scaling but the big if you can
look at the details but really the big
message is that the number of Clifford
gates is independent of the number of
qubits and that has to do again with
this end independent transversality
property yeah
so this transversality property gives us
that the yeah so the density of non
clifford gates is allowed to go to zero
as the number of qubits goes to infinity
so yeah because the active ingredient is
being diluted and the works we call it
homeopathy so there you are so that's
another application and yeah so with
this I end and I my heart is bleeding
that the part I this happens in every
presentation that you forgot this I want
to talk about the representation
theoretic version which is very cool but
it would take extra time and I always
save it for the end of it and I have
never time to talk about at some point
of time I will tell the world about what
this has to do with how do allottee and
but not today because my time is up and
I just want to say that there's a great
work with the PhD student here Philippe
in Montenegro whoaaah who might be
finished in about a year so if you want
a great postdoc it can write him an
email and let me summarize yeah
so we have worked out the competent
algebra of powers of the clifford group
we have found and continued to find many
applications including to testing and I
didn't tell you but it's so true that we
made progress on what is called the
failure of how do ality which would
actually be called how gosh she wore
around reality in final dimensions but
that is for another day
thank you okay thank you very much David
for the wonderful presentation so this
is the time for you to start writing
questions and raise your hands and
otherwise we will actually not leave
David's hearts bleeding and and I have
to ask you to give us a two-minute
version of your the last thing that you
wanted to tell us that I okay all right
okay it would be polite now to wait for
questions to come up but since my heart
is actually reading I will accept your
kind offer and we'll try to keep in two
minutes
it's okay Q in two years all right okay
so we want to know had everybody in and
do ask questions in the Q&A box all
right okay so so our representation
stop the so far only works in all
dimensions we're working on the even
qubit case but we don't have it yet
because in what dimensions the Clifford
group is much simpler it has a simple
structure namely
in what I mentioned the Clifford group
is essentially a representation of a
symplectic group of a symplectic group
of a finite vector space just as we had
orthogonal mappings in this final
scenario one can also define synthetic
ones and that is what the Clifford group
is if I'm what other parties yeah and
now I can this reminds us now closely to
the action of canonical maps on face
base now that you know from quantum
optics or from classical mechanics and
so let let me present you with the
classic result of how Kajiwara and then
about about how what is known as how do
additi for continuous variable systems
yeah so we forget about quantum
information now it's continuous
variables so every block here is now a a
mode l2 of are and now I have n modes
and I want to again look at T copies of
n modes yeah and on every copy and on I
we like collection of n modes I have the
canonical operations acting and they are
acting as as SP of are to the to n the
the canonical V the symplectic
symmetries
we have there and again we can look now
at the T for tens of power of this meta
plactic representation and it turns out
that has been known for a long time that
the commitment is actually the
orthogonal group the T by T we all saw a
hoop now no funky model arithmetic just
the normal orthogonal group and yeah in
this statement is called hard reality
and an X in the same way as I said
before our the sweetstuff acted so in a
way we have proven that this continuous
version also exists as quickly yeah and
and also I just said this is the
algebraic version but there's also a
representation theoretic version so the
Hilbert space decomposes just like it
does in show wide reality in terms of
pairs of irreducible representations of
the orthogonal group and the syntactical
okay so now but we know now that for
dimensions the Clifford group is
basically the same just where I replaced
the real numbers with integers mod D so
I've done it here so it's exactly the
same slide everything is exactly as
before just that R has been replaced by
ZD everywhere and then we get the the
Clifford group yeah and again we have
this representation theoretically
composition but now comes the one
difference that these representations
are no longer irreducible they are now
reducible in general and that was known
since the 1970s so in fact how before I
did it's continuous variable theorem he
tried to solve the discrete case and at
this point he stopped because he there
was a reducibility and a problem that he
couldn't get rid of yeah and now we can
work this out so we can decompose these
we can decompose these reducible spaces
and the big and the big ingredient is
CSS course these are the CSS codes so
basically what we can do is I mean now
we're back because I have the one-minute
version or the 10-second version yes so
so these are right okay so these
representations the triple
representations they decompose and and
there is one kind of like biggest chunk
in every such block and there is a bunch
of smaller representations and they all
arise from the the the restriction of
the representation onto these CSS codes
so basically the the failure of our
reality to hold in finite fields can be
completely explained by using CSS
several thousand CSS codes and so I
think it's very cute but very very nice
that we can use a quantum information
idea to to solve this representation of
the illogic problem okay so now that I
told you what we did in a very rough way
I can also look at the outlook and the
outlook is so before we we want to do it
for qubits and we are like in the
process of doing it so far it's only who
in what I mentions because it's easier
there and and we don't actually have any
quantum information applications of that
yet at all but I'm sure
that we and what the community would
come up with them in due course so thank
you to read for giving me like the two
minutes and yeah then really Robin do
you want to ask quickly your question
sure
David thank you you've you've stunned me
into submission with the Clifford stuff
so I'm gonna fall back and ask since you
gave an introduction to tomography in
the context of this workshop I was
wondering if you had any comments for
the the non experts in the audience on
other kinds of tomography besides state
tomography process tomography detector
tomography etc Yeah right okay so not
sure I have big comment there no as I
said before tomography as you know of
course Robins a gigantic field with
libraries being written about and
already he gave like a very long list of
different like sub questions one can ask
different parameters in the very
beginning and of course there's many
more dimensions as Robin said know if
you yeah here I mean another column it
would be what are the objects you want
to learn about I kind of use stage
because its simplest then there is
processes which is maybe more relevant
actually in practice because people have
like gates they want to certify no and
then if you if you want to learn about
gates it's even the measurement models
become even more complex because you you
want to have measurements that effect to
rise into something to do with the input
and something you measure on the output
yeah detector tomography it's kind of
dual to stay to market so I think that's
not so different of course the big
problem is what if you have no
information about either your state or
your detectors in which case for example
gates a tomography tries to addresses
yeah okay so what I want to say is I'm
not sure I have any coherent message
it's just it's a very big field and it
has even more dimensions than the one
I've sketched here kind of a known
answer sorry I'm not sure I can do any
better thank you okay thank you very
much David for this wonderful talk I
think we'll reconvene in henries this
half an hour
Oh
well I guess then in 15 minutes the
maybe let's add five more minutes just
to have a 15 minute break so you can
start at 11:35 okay thank you David yeah
thank you for putting reputable